[Musique]
tu es l'Indien dans le cœur de l'enfant
documentaire réalisé par gwen lawen le
green un film vous venez de le voir qui
retrace le long combat culturel
politique et juridique des défenseurs de
la cause amérindienne au Canada pourquoi
ces vertus aussi importants aujourd'hui
de protéger les peuples autochtones par
le monde et bien nous allons en débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débat doc en commençant
par vous Irène Bellier bienvenue vous
êtes anthropologue directrice de
recherche et mérite au CNRS ces membres
du laboratoire d'anthropologie politique
à l'ache et au CNRS vous êtes également
entre autres bien sûr auteur de ce livre
échelle de gouvernance et droits des
peuples autochtones un ouvrage publié
chez L'Harmattan et que vous avez dirigé
avec Jennifer Ace cet ouvrage explore la
complexité des relations de pouvoir qui
pèse sur la reconnaissance des peuples
autochtones et la mise en oeuvre de
leurs droits on y viendra bien entendu
avec vous dans cette émission Sylvie
Briot est également avec nous bienvenue
vous êtes grand reporter et écrivain
membre de la nationale géographique
Society et de la Société des
Explorateurs français votre dernier
ouvrage s'intitule lui l'âme de
l'Amérique au coeur des grands espaces
de l'Ouest il est disponible chez Albin
Michel et puis fiorellongo est également
avec nous bienvenue vous êtes vous aussi
anthropologue et responsable de
recherche et de plaidoyer à Survival
International mouvement mondial pour le
droit justement des peuples autochtones
vous dirigez survival France et sur
valbuil Espagne vous publiez chez double
ponctuation
décolonisons la protection de la nature
plaidoyer pour les peuples autochtones
et l'environnement parce que c'est vrai
aujourd'hui l'essentiel de la
biodiversité se trouve sur les
territoires des peuples autochtones on y
reviendra évidemment à l'occasion de
cette émission nous venons de voir ce
documentaire tourner au Canada première
question peut-être avec vous parce que
il faut peut-être en revenir tout
simplement aux origines nous avons à
faire avec les peuples autochtones à des
peuples qui ont été victimes
de la colonisation et ce que nous avons
vu dans ce film n'est qu'une conséquence
finalement de cette grande période de
colonisation Johnson Trudeau le Premier
ministre
canadien a même parlé d'un génocide
concernant ces populations sur son
territoire le Canada on peut parler
aujourd'hui d'un génocide concernant les
peuples autochtones notamment en
Amérique du Nord je pense que le thème
est parfaitement approprié et bien de le
retenir aujourd'hui parce qu'on a en
effet connaissance de ce que ces peuples
ont été colonisés exterminés spolié
relégué dans les terres les moins
fertiles possibles déplacés de manière
forcée et finalement tout ceci
correspond à parfaitement au terme de la
Convention sur le génocide la prévention
des génocides et de la torture qui est
en effet l'interdiction de déplacer ces
populations là et ça a été fait par le
fait de la colonisation et on a jusqu'à
présent pas considéré comme des
génocides alors que l'on sait très bien
que la population si on ne prend que la
population des Amériques aujourd'hui
elle a été réduite à peu près peut-être
5 10% maximum de la population initiale
et ça c'est un phénomène de génocide
moi-même j'ai travaillé chez les peuples
autochtones en Amazonie et ils ont été
là j'ai les chiffres on a compté réduit
à 10% de leur population à la fin du 19e
siècle c'est considérable quand vous
avez 90% d'une population qui décède et
c'est à sa compagne également de la de
la spoliation territoriale c'est-à-dire
qu'on leur prend les terres des colons
arrivent s'installent se posent et les
considères surtout ce qui est le plus
problématique et que je pense on on
mesure toujours aujourd'hui les les
conséquences de ce phénomène-là
c'est-à-dire qu'on les a considérés
comme des non-humains comme des sauvages
comme des barbares comme les ignorants
comme des gens qu'il fallait évangéliser
pour les amener à être comme nous le
nous étant le nous dominant c'est
vraiment le politique
notamment par le Canada on l'a vu dans
ce documentaire pas le Canada par les
États-Unis par toutes les Amériques par
tous les pays les Américains y compris
par la France donc la volonté en effet
de ne pas considérer ces gens pour la
différence culturelle les différences
linguistiques vous pouvez avoir leur
manière différenciée qui les faisaient
au mieux être considéré comme voilà sur
le plan folklorique ça peut être
intéressant sur le plan touristique
peut-être que ça peut être intéressant
mais reconnaître que ces personnes-là
ces ensembles là ces peuples
c'est-à-dire plus que des communautés
ont à la fois un rapport au territoire
qui est particulier une manière de vivre
et de tirer leur subsistance qui est
infiniment moins prédatrice que celle de
nos sociétés
occidentales développées industriels est
un point important et aujourd'hui dans
le Canada en particulier on a on parle
non seulement de génocide mais aussi on
peut parler de des effets de la
colonisation de peuplement c'est à dire
qu'il y a eu remplacement de la
population locale par les les colons qui
sont arrivés et qui ont finalement au
fil de l'histoire du Canada ou fil de
l'histoire des États-Unis
fait plus attention dans le cadre du
multiculturalisme aux populations qui
venaient de différentes parties du monde
qu'au population autochtones qui ont été
relégués sur même pas 5% du territoire
qui autrefois possédait évidemment toute
le territoire et au milieu de tout cela
ce sont
les pensionnats qui ont joué au Canada
et aux États-Unis ce rôle absolument
abominable de tuer l'Indien dans le cœur
de l'enfant pour le 25 conseils enfant
canadien sont passés par ces
pensionnats catholiques et 4000 de ses
enfants en sont morts on décide là des
violences des humiliations subies par
ces enfants au sein de ces pensionnats
on a appris tout ça avec avec ce film
que faut-il retenir pour l'essentiel
[Musique]
dans le film que nous venons de voir
du côté du Canada alors en fait la
problématique c'est poser également du
côté des États-Unis il y a un pensionnat
qui est tristement célèbre aux
États-Unis qui s'appelle Carline qui se
situe en Pennsylvanie et qui a inspiré
entre guillemets ce modèle de pensionnat
au Canada il a été créé par un officier
de l'armée américaine en 1860 et ça
devise et celle qui est à l'origine du
titre du film c'était tué l'Indien pour
sauver l'homme et
en fait c'est vrai que ça a été à
l'origine de déstructuration familiales
parce qu'on a arraché les enfants à leur
famille on les a privés de leur identité
on les a privés de leur culture on les a
privés de leur langue et quand ils sont
venus dans leur famille les familles
étaient non seulement déstructurées mais
il y avait une perte de repères et de
sens et aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de
gens qui parlent qui dénigrent ces
communautés en me disant il y a beaucoup
de cas d'alcoolisme et de drogues mais
il faut pas oublier d'une chose que
c'est que quand on a obligé les Indiens
à se sédentariser il y en a beaucoup qui
étaient nomades des peuples nomades
libres on les a forcés à se lancer
danser je prends le cas par exemple des
États-Unis en échange de traités qu'ils
ont signé et qui ont été violés par le
gouvernement américain on leur proposait
de se sédentariser et on leur offrait
des rations alimentaires qui ne sont où
jamais parvenus aux communautés ou qui
était avariées et on leur fournissait
également de l'alcool pour anesthésier
leur résistance donc tout ça a conduit à
au drame qu'on connaît aujourd'hui et au
problème aussi au cycle de la violence
qui est qui ne cesse en fait de se
répéter donc addiction chez les plus
jeunes on l'a vu aussi dans dans ce film
mais c'est pas seulement vrai au Canada
double peine pour les femmes aussi les
féminiciens concernant les femmes et ça
se donne les chiffres sont là aussi
très troublants et effrayant d'une
certaine manière on parle de 7 fois plus
de féminicides du côté des femmes
autochtones que chez les femmes blanches
dans la
cette région qui nous concerne dans ce
film donc Canada États-Unis c'est le
même problème en fait au nord des
États-Unis on retrouve ce problème et
aux États-Unis l'Institut national pour
la justice
le son dernier rapport dit que quatre
femmes autochtones sur 5 expérimente la
violence au cours de leur vie donc c'est
vraiment dramatique il y a ce phénomène
de qu'on appelle missing murder woman
donc ces femmes qui disparaissent ou
qu'on retrouve assassinés et pour et
pour ces cas en fait il n'y a jamais
aucune investigation qui sont menées de
la part des autorités et c'est ce que
dénonce les autochtones des deux côtés
de la frontière disons cela vous
confirmez ce qui nous a été démontré
absolument quand on va dans les réserves
là j'étais récemment quand on va dans
certaines réserves il y a beaucoup de
panneaux de David recherche pour des
jeunes femmes d'une vingtaine d'années
ou des adolescentes qui disparaissent et
dont on est sans nouvelles donc c'est
les familles comme on l'a vu dans le
film qui essaient de faire pression sur
les autorités avec les moyens qu'elles
ont pour que les enquêtes soient Ré pour
qu'elle ne soit pas abandonnée et pour
qu'on obtenir enfin
des réponses aux questions qu'elles se
posent qu'est-ce que vous voulez
rajouter à ce qui est déjà été dit
qu'est-ce que vous a frappé vous dans
les leçons à retenir après avoir vu ce
film
j'étais en train de réfléchir de choses
qui ont été dit parce que une chose qui
m'a frappé un particulier en parlant
aussi des États-Unis qui est les centres
des côtés la question de pensionnats qui
sont été des institutions précises dans
un moment précises toutes les films
auraient possédé le lait dans n'importe
quel pays avec les dans lesquels il y a
des peuples autochtones donc la question
du racisme d'accès à la justice la
discrimination les racines de la police
les féminicides tout ça sont des les
taux de suicides des alcoolisme tout ça
c'est partout où les popotocons ont été
expulsés dans leur terre donc
je pense que les films et encore plus
des grandes actualités en concerne la
situation des popotochtones aujourd'hui
donc aujourd'hui on a appris les
pensionnats on part dans cette forme là
on a aussi les scolarité encore les
scolarisation forcées les enfants et
dans certains pays et mais quand même
les racisme permet et encore dans notre
institutions y compris en France bien
sûr pour les pays pour lesquels les
popottants inexistent pas il a des
populations autochtones à pas des poples
donc on est encore dans un corps de
racisme institutionnel qui empêche
l'accès à la justice qui empêche l'accès
à la santé par exemple mais aussi on est
encore dans une situation dans laquelle
époque autochtones sont expulsés de leur
terre parce qu'elles sont considérés
primitives où ils sont considérés
arrière et une cas particuliers que je
tiens à souligner c'est aussi celle de
la conservation à la protection de la
nature parce qu'aujourd'hui on a un
corps cette mentalité raciste envers les
peuples autochtones dans les projets des
conservations on pense que la manière
dans laquelle il chasse aux particules
la pêche
ah un impact négatif sur l'environnement
et
pour nous remettre en tête où se situe
l'essentiel des populations autochtones
aujourd'hui dans le monde les peuples
autochtones sont présents dans 70 pays
sur les cinq continents répartis en près
de 5000 groupes humains avec des
identités et des cultures radicalement
différentes les deux tiers des peuples
autochtones dans le monde vivent en Asie
ce qui représente entre 260 et 370
millions d'individus ensuite arrivent
l'Afrique ou notamment 40 millions de
Peuls sont présents donc 15 États
africains différents l'Amérique du Sud
ensuite avec principalement des
populations autochtones présentes au
Mexique au Guatemala et au Brésil et
puis ensuite arrive l'Amérique du Nord
avec les États-Unis qui comptent environ
3 millions d'individus
issus des peuples autochtones et le
Canada avec 1,5 millions d'individus et
puis enfin l'Australie et l'Océanie est
également représenté avec plus de 500
peuples aborigènes distincts en
Australie généralement d'ailleurs divisé
en clan chacun ayant sa propre langue et
son propre territoire
cette diversité est impressionnante
néanmoins il y a eu un grand pas en
avant il y a eu un grand marqueur dans
la défense des droits des pommes
autochtones c'est cette fameuse
Déclaration des Nations Unies pour les
droits des peuples autochtones c'est en
2007 il y a eu un avant et un après 2007
concernant les autochtones on peut dire
les choses comme ça ça a été une avancée
considérable dans la protection des
peuples autochtones je pense que c'est
important on espère que les peuples
autochtones soient encore des Autonomes
c'est important ils sont surtout
qualifiés maintenant comme faisant
partie et ça c'est un point très
important de cette déclaration de
l'humanité c'est à dire que quelque part
en reconnaissant le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux-mêmes le droit des
peuples autochtones indisposé de même on
les met on les place l'ensemble de
l'humanité alors qu'ils étaient
considérés avant comme je l'ai dit
précédemment comme des sauvages des
barbares des ignorants des incapables
etc donc là il rentre effectivement dans
cette considération là et cette
déclaration a pris presque 25 ans plus
de 25 ans pour être négocié il y a eu
beaucoup de dynamiques internationales
de création qui commence je crois au
milieu des années 60 sur les premiers
mouvements de défense des peuples
autochtones et pour en arriver à 2007
c'est relativement récent c'est très
récent ça a été très très difficile et
il y a encore une un non d'accord je
dirais international sur la
qualification sur la reconnaissance même
comme peuple autochtones parce que dans
peuple autochtones vous avez deux choses
vous avez ce qui était là avant la
colonisation qui ont effectivement qui
sont déterminés à maintenir leur société
leur langue leur culture leurs
institutions vivantes leurs institutions
de gouvernance leur système de justice
et c'est important de reconnaître qu'ils
ont des systèmes de justice et pas
simplement des
us et coutumes parce que effectivement
le droit positif a reconnu des
mais également la notion de peuple et là
pour qualifier dans l'égalité des droits
et ce qui a été problématique et qui est
intéressant avec l'acquis de la
Déclaration des Nations Unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones il y a
quand même été acquise avec au départ
143 voies pour 10 voix 4 voix contre le
bloc des contre c'était le Canada
l'Australie de la Nouvelle-Zélande et
les États-Unis
qui sont qui qui avait une angoisse
énorme sur effectivement que faire de
ces territoires qui ont été colonisés
dans lequel ils ont relégué des
populations autochtones à rien du tout
mais finalement ils ont tous ces quatre
pays acceptés et il y a d'autres pays
qui sont en train de l'adopter ou qui
sont en train de revenir sur leurs
abstention par exemple
et dans l'ensemble du monde on peut dire
qu'il n'y a plus de d'objections
directes contre les droits des peuples
autochtones mais le point principal
aujourd'hui c'est de faire appliquer
cette déclaration donc il y a eu
plusieurs réunions aux Nations Unies qui
qui se tiennent chaque année les
autochtones viennent participent de
l'instance permanente sur les questions
tochtones du mécanisme d'expert sur les
droits des peuples autochtones pour
arriver à montrer non seulement qu'ils
ont des droits à faire respecter mais
également l'ensemble des sujets de la
planète le changement climatique le
développement durable les concerts
également et que l'on cesse de prendre
des décisions qui peuvent les concerner
sans leur accord sans leur participation
sans leur prise leur participation à la
prise de décision et ça c'est un point
très important parce que vous avez par
exemple une minière qui arrive et qui va
décide par exemple le gouvernement
canadien va dire bon bah ok concession
pour telle entreprise minière ça va être
bien pour le développement local
l'emploi local etc et quand on a
complètement bouleversé l'environnement
d'une part et par ailleurs c'est pas du
tout certain que ça soit bon pour
l'emploi local c'est pas du tout certain
que ça soit bénéfique au bénéfice des
populations et des peuples autochtones
locaux et c'est sur des enjeux de lutte
très très présents sur pratiquement tous
les sujets possibles la construction
d'une route parce que aujourd'hui la
Terre a été pratiquement maillée de de
phénomènes de de
urbain d'urbanisation de construction de
route de de pôles de développement et du
coup il faut prendre un moment donné la
mesure de
est-ce que l'on doit déplacer ces gens
là pour le bénéfice d'une entreprise
multinationale externe à ce peuple là je
suis pas certaine toutes ces difficultés
c'est de faire cohabiter cette
déclaration
concernant la protection des peuples
autochtones et la législation de chaque
pays là on a l'exemple du Canada dans le
film que nous avons vu mais ça c'est
réellement compliqué donc il y a le
contexte international puis après il y a
le contexte dans chaque État dans chaque
pays là ce qui a avancé par exemple aux
États-Unis c'est qu'avec l'élection de
Joe Biden il y a deb alun qui a été
nommé secrétaire d'État à l'intérieur et
des bananes elle est membre de la nation
Laguna pueblo donc autochtone du
Nouveau-Mexique et elle a en charge
c'est une première qu'une autochtone est
en charge la gestion des terres
fédérales la gestion des réserves
amérindiennes la gestion des parcs
nationaux et la gestion de la délivrance
des permis pour
forer les terres et pour en extraire les
richesses donc de ce côté là il y a eu
des avancées mais la déclaration dont on
parlait des Nations Unies sur les
peuples autochtones elle n'est pas
contraignante c'est peut-être aussi ça
le problème pour l'appliquer dans chaque
État en tout cas il y a quand même des
avancées il y a quand même des
autochtones qui arrivent à accéder à des
fonctions essentielles au cœur de chaque
État comme c'est le cas dans ce dans
l'État aux États-Unis mais je peux
compléter sur ce point si vous me
permettez le Canada à adopter le 21 juin
2021 et une loi de mise en oeuvre de la
Déclaration des Nations Unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones donc il
essaye en effet de mettre en accord ça
ça législation avec les le côté on dit
en anglais aspirationnel c'est-à-dire
que cette déclaration elle n'est pas
contraignante comme la signaler très
bien très justement Sylvie Brieuc mais
elle vise à transformer
les cadres législatifs aussi les états
de pensée les structures sociales et les
institutions donc c'est inspirant
pour la transformation et il faut s'y
accorder les avancées elles existent au
Canada notamment avec un dédommagement
historiques qui a été décrété par le
gouvernement
canadien on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans ce
documentaire le combat qu'il a fallu
mener
du côté des des peuples concernés en
Australie aussi puisque le tout nouveau
gouvernement socialiste s'est engagé à
créer un organe représentatif des
peuples indigènes
organe qui serait un organe
institutionnel et ça nécessite
d'ailleurs de modifier la Constitution
australienne
on avance
est-ce qu'on avance sachant que là on
parle de de grands États et que c'est
vrai qu'il y a un certain nombre de
peuples autochtones dont on ne parle pas
et qui qui eux se voient menacer dans
leur droit réellement parce qu'ils ne
font peut-être pas partie non plus de
grands États ou les choses avancent oui
alors en même temps oui on avance au
point de vue législatif c'est vrai qu'il
y a beaucoup beaucoup de gens sur
majoridiques avant inexistait pas soit
la déclaration et là aussi on convention
de l'organisation internationale de
travail on a des constitutions des pays
telles que la Colombie car elle connaît
les droits à la terre des popottes mais
les problèmes des basses pour les popoto
que ton articuler c'est l'accès à la
terre donc le droit territoriant et ça
demande un changement très radical
un niveau politique parce que ça veut
dire que c'est que je vais vous dire que
c'est pour quel étroits et pour quelle
époque autochtone puis jouir de toutes
leurs droits ils ont besoin de leur
territoire ils sont un lien très très
important à la terre donc l'accès à la
santé c'est aussi l'accès à la terre
l'accès à
l'exercice et leur rituel et de leur
mort de vie c'est à l'accès à la terre
et aujourd'hui on a un attaque des plus
en plus plus important à envers leur
territoire qui sont riches en ressources
et en biodiversité et donc d'un côté on
a des avancées législatives mais le côté
la croissance de nos économies impose
qu'il y en a besoin des plus en plus de
ressources et qui se trouve derrière la
majorité des cas dans les pop autochton
c'est les cas par exemple à la
maçonnerie on a bien même si les récits
il y a des lois mises en place qui sont
des lois très bien et à l'avant-garde
sur la question des pop autochtones
c'est suffisant un précédent qui veut
vendre les ressources du pays et pour
que tout ça soit mis en discussion donc
on a d'un côté la question des laters et
des nudes croissance économique parce
qu'il y en avait souvent des ressources
et de l'autre côté aussi comme Michel
expliqué avant la question de la
protection de la nature parce qu'elle
est plus en plus de leur terre ils pour
la création des aires protégés pour la
vente des crédits de carbone donc des
projets des compensation des nos
émissions des carbone donc on a un
attaque moi c'est nos expériences à
survival qui vient d'un côté il y a
vraiment des avancées de l'autre côté il
y a un attaque sans précédent dans les
pots de temps soit au nom de la
protection de la nature soit au nombre
de développement sur le nombre de
ressources économiques je reste avec
vous parce que ça c'est vraiment votre
domaine j'ai précisé que les peuples
autochtones représentants représentaient
5% de la population mondiale mais le
représente aussi 80% des réserves en
matière de biodiversité sur notre
planète ça peut-être que tout le monde
le sait pas ce qui nous regarde ne le
savent peut-être pas tous mais c'est ça
c'est un enjeu majeur pour la protection
des démotochtones au nom de la
protection notre planète est-ce que tout
le monde comprend bien ça ce qu'on a
bien pris conscience de ça dans les
instances internationales notamment
aujourd'hui non ça commence à changer un
peu de plus en plus
on parle des popottants comme elle est
meilleure gardiens de la nature mais
comme je disais dans les discours dans
la pratique non ça c'est passe pas on
sait très bien que les 80% de la
biodiversité se trouve dans les
territoires autochtones qui représente
seulement autour les bandes pour cent de
la terre donc et on sait très bien que
dans leur territoire il n'y a pas
seulement beaucoup de biodiversités
par exemple donc et ça c'est pas par
hasard c'est pas question de trouver
avec toutes ces biodiversité c'est parce
qu'à l'époque autochtones ils ont un
rôle actif dans la création de la
biodiversité les endroits les plus
biodiverses au monde on pense à la
maçonnerie on pense à les forêts du
Bassin du Congo ils ont été façonnés par
des popoto donc les popotins ils font
des choses il y a ils ont une
interaction avec l'environnement qui
crée de la richesse et la richesse donc
et ça est mis en discussion tous les
temps on n'est plus en plus on a des
projets des expulsion des popottants
pour Claire des parcs naturels donc ça
nous peut semblait contradictoire parce
que analyser s'il protégeait la nature
pourquoi on les expulse et leur terre
mais l'idée des bas c'est à l'époque
autochton encore aujourd'hui ils sont
arriérés ils comprennent pas comment
gérer leur environnement donc c'est à
nous de l'expliquer ça c'est très
pressant même dans les projets français
des aides au projet environnementaux
donc même dans la coopération
internationale française ces types des
mentalités la réponse vient des nous
nous savons mieux c'est encore présent
et c'est absolument dommage
au-delà d'être illégales parce que les
popoto qu'on finisse pour être expulsés
mais comme vous l'avez dit aujourd'hui
on sait très bien que si on protège on
les aide à protéger leur droit
territoriales donc si eux sont
les droits territoriaux sont respectés
il peut vivre dans leur forêt dans leur
savane on a une croissance des
biodiversité des animaux donc des
l'écosystème
et ça ça les convient pas seulement un
peu autochton c'est bien aussi pour nous
parce que on sait très bien qu'il a
destruction des destructions
environnementales et aussi les
changements climatiques sont en train de
détruire toute notre planète qui essaie
notre maison commence dans laquelle on
habite tous donc la communauté
internationale notamment à travers les
cops alors il y a une COP15 qui s'est
déroulée d'ailleurs justement au Canada
qui s'est déroulé à la fin de l'année
dernière qui ne voulait pas répéter les
erreurs de la COP précédente la Coop de
Glasgow ou 1,7 milliards de dollars
avaient été débloqué en faveur des
peuples autochtones mais alors seulement
19% avaient été débloqué de ces aides et
alors 7% seulement sont allés
directement au peuple concerné on a tout
de même un vrai problème là aussi non on
a un problème d'échelle on a un problème
d'instrumentalisation aussi de de ces
différentes cops et aujourd'hui on est
en train de penser que on peut arriver
par la Financière d'une certaine manière
à résoudre problème et je crois qu'il
faut compléter la financearisation par
un changement de logiciel vis-à-vis en
effet de la capacité de la
reconnaissance de la capacité de ces
peuples à pouvoir préserver
l'environnement non seulement pour
eux-mêmes mais pour l'ensemble de
l'humanité comme disait même ses
enveloppes qui pourraient amener à très
compliqué à gérer même parce qu'en fait
nous on est dans un système capitaliste
financier avec des systèmes ne sont pas
ils ne sont pas encore ils sont pas
habitués à gérer les investissements sur
50 ans ils avaient des sociétés qui sont
sur le plan de des modes de subsistance
extraordinairement diverses et il y a
peu à peu l'économie monétaire est en
train de rentrer mais c'est pas
forcément au bénéfice de ces populations
là parfois ça les rend juste très
pauvres et c'est cette pauvreté là qui
qui est insupportable à accepter et je
pense qu'en effet aujourd'hui on est
dans un dans un dans un moment où on est
en train de commencer à reconnaître que
les savoirs autochtones sont des savoirs
précieux pour l'ensemble de l'humanité
il faut arriver à les considérer non pas
comme des éléments de patrimoine mais
comme les éléments de de vie commun
qu'il ne faut pas s'approprier par la
marchandisation parce qu'en fait nous le
logiciel finalement
occidental c'est on met un prix sur
chaque chose et on arrive à peu près à
gérer les affaires c'est pas toujours
avec la avec ses moyens là qu'on y
arrive en revanche et c'est là où on
retrouve peut-être la question du du
documentaire que nous avons vu c'est
probablement par la restauration de
l'estime de soi la reconnaissance de la
capacité à gérer ces écosystèmes la
maîtrise de l'environnement
le fait que ces personnes ont
véritablement des savoirs et pas
simplement des vagues connaissances
pratiques locales et quand on commence à
penser que on a affaire à des savoirs
autochtones on rentre dans une
discussion sur quelle relation entre
savoir autochtone et savoir scientifique
et ça oblige à changer le notre manière
de penser je voulais pour rebondir sur
ce que vous venez de dire Irène bélier
que il participe les autochtones
eux-mêmes à ce changement de logiciel
parce que aujourd'hui il y a des
autochtones qui accèdent enfin qui sont
cinéastes qui sont écrivains et qui
participent aussi à la décolonisation de
mode de pensée qui fait que on les
considéré comme des Indiens folkloriques
ou comme des autochtones folkloriques et
il y a pour faire le lien direct avec le
film il y a une grande dame du cinéma
par exemple canadien qui est d'origine à
benakis à l'anis aux bonnes saouine qui
a fait un nombre de films considérables
de documentaires qui ont participé à
faire changer les lois au Canada en
faveur des peuples autochtones merci ce
sera malheureusement le mot de la fin on
a voulu passer davantage de temps avec
vous vraiment pour parler de ces
pop-toktones et de la nécessité de les
protéger aujourd'hui j'espère qu'on l'a
bien compris vous écoutant
chacune d'entre vous vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
merci aussi à sel massali qui comme à
l'accoutumée m'a aidé à améliorer cette
émission je vous donne bien sûr
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
avec son documentaire et son débat à
très bientôt
[Musique]